'S EVANDER KANE!
THAT HIT THE SIDE OF THE NET AND
RANG THE P Craig: FOR EVANDER K,
YOU REMEMBER THE SEVEN GOALS IN
SERIESES
TRYING TO SWING IT IN FRONT AND
GOTTG OUT IN FRONT, TRYING TO
GET IN WA WAS STOP BÖM HAS TO
TURN IN THIS SERIES, CHRIS.
>> NUMBERS ARE
REALLY QUITE SHOCKING.
IT HE HAD HIS GLOVE OUT IN
FRONT TO NOT ALLOW
>> Craig: AFTER WINNING THE
DRAW AND GOING DOWN THE S S OWN
DEFLECTION BY THE FLAMES THERE,
ONE-TIMER, MCDAVID AT THE OTHER.
SO OFTEN THEY WERE GOING D IT
OUT BUT MCDAVID IN.
ZACH HYMAN A BACKHAND!
SEASON
GAMES AND LOOKING FOR HIS FIRST
E
NUMBER THREE.
FAR WITH FIVE SHOTS ON G THE FI.
DEREK RYAN, AND MARKSTRÖM'S
GOING TOUT IN
FRONT!
AND MARKSTRÖM WITH THE STOP. BO.
CONNOR MCDAVID, YAMAMOTO LOOKING
FOR ROOM IN
DASH.
>> Craig: :
AWAY.
SCOOPED DOWN BYT HOW FAR
MARKSTRÖM HAS TO COME ACROSS.
HE'S THINKING SHOT BY DRAISAITL,
NOW HE'S
A PASS BACK.
LEWIS WAS HEADING
YOU'VE GOT A BAD CHANGE, A
TURNOVER TO THE EXACT WRONGRE HY
LINE BUT DRAISAITL'S GOING TO
PUT OUT THE FIRE AND WORK IT TO
D
A T THERE AND NOW MCDAVID
AHEAD TO FOEGELE AND JUMPING
INTO THE RUSH.
.>> Chris: 14 SAVES MORE MIKE
SMITH SO FAR IN THE SLOT.
AND AWAY GOES MCDAVID AND
CA AND
ANOTHER SIDE-BY-SIDE, THAT'S
THREE MARKSTR
GAUDREAU WATCHED BY MCLEOD.
RINK WIDE
DUBE CHASING AFTER IT, TOFFOLI
FOLLOWS
>> C PASS
FOR
COUNTER.
DUBE'S SHOT HIGH, KEPT INT.
HE BREAKS HIS STICK.
KEPT IN BY ANDERSSON.